[Musique]
dessange
ça remonte à quelques années puisque
avant d'être jacques dessange eux qu'on
connaît dans le monde entier et bien du
côté de sous m las de la sologne
il y avait un petit jacques dessange
alors on va faire on va découvrir ce
qu'on appelle nous l'album de famille
avec quelques photos que vous avez
apporté oui d'accord relevé oui
absolument
ça va c'est parti voilà la première
photo qui va nous permettre de voir
jacques dessange un petit peu plus jeune
mon dieu regardez sa remontée vers et
cheveux à l'époque époque
vous savez que j'ai lancé une ligne de
produits capillaires et de tafer début
j'ai fait des expériences qui n'ont pas
très bien évident que je n'allais pas
que j'avais beaucoup de jeu et que nul
n'est prophète en son pays
c'est une photo que le même qu'un
question t'es fabienne qui était à même
qu'un de ses carnets saisis dans les
années 1950 la première photo de de
presse qui est passé d'une coiffure que
j'avais fait ça devienne le super
mannequin des années 50
de quel milieu de vie sur jacques
dessange parce que on est allé en
sologne as well
vos parents qu'est ce qui faisait le
père était chauffeur votre père était
coiffeur votre mère ma mère vous savez à
la campagne le coiffeur c'est un peu le
drugstore du village ma mère s'occupait
du bistrot mon père était photographe il
était aussi maudit il y avait beaucoup
de commerces le village de sous m à
l'époque il y avait 12 cents habitants
il ya toujours deux cents habitants
d'ailleurs c'était vraiment un village
très très perdu donc on voulait faire
ses courses on passait dans le salon à
côté pour saper le et si on était
contents on buvait un petit café ou un
petit apéro la même si on n'était pas
content on buvait un café quand même et
surtout un apéro alors ça c'est une
faute aux vacances vous l'avez reconnu
celle il a réussi là-bas j'ai coupé ses
couettes il ya un certain nombre
d'années
lors de la ligne du ni vers sers de mon
des princes d'années d'existence de mon
salon je lui ai rendu gecko être car je
les avais gardés précieusement gardée
niveau est élevé ce qu'elle le savait ça
non non très content de les retrouver je
fais un belle boucle
je crois qu'elle est belle et bum dans
un superbe 4 bon là vous avez donc vous
l'avez reconnu ces matériels sont
élevées à ses débuts puisque je crois
même que cette photo est et une photo
que j'avais fait moi-même ce jeudi faute
aussi à l'épaule c'est une photo qui a
illustré sa première pochette de disque
quand vous regardez cette photo il ya
des modes qui vous feront sourire
comme nom auquel vous n'avez pas adhérer
la coiffure de dany par exemple la
voiture de devises elle avait 18 ans des
nids l'arrivée à paris et j'ai déjà
commencé comme le dal chez moi avant de
devenir chanteuse
oui à cette photo mais je considère
qu'elle a maintenant 25 ans elle n'est
pas déposée par les fautes les coiffures
que je faisais et 25 ou 30 ans sont
encore d'actualité
il n'y a pas d'aidés des modes coop
n'avons pas renié les beatniks sel et
des hommes qui avaient les cheveux longs
vous n'avez pas adhérer à l on n'est pas
du tout à ce courant non parce que
j'aime que les femmes soient belles et
je crois que par la voiture on peut
apporter
là c'est la fameuse choucroute de
brigitte il ya un an on y revient très
fort oui c'est non des cheveux longs et
le bébé absolument les cheveux longs
blonds remontés en chignon comme ça ça
c'est une perruque et la porte et je ne
sais plus pour qu'elle fume ça qu'on
n'en parle pas souvent des perruques ça
se porte encore beaucoup non mais il ya
une grande malle il ya une grande motte
de l'intérêt il ya une vingtaine
d'années les stars elles font beaucoup
pour la pour la coiffure
j'étais comme ça louise brooks ça c'est
une c'est la photo le brigitte quand
elle a tourné la vérité d'une perruque
également je pensais à louise brooks le
style joue t il lancé à jean seberg et
c'est là c'est la posture et est un
vieux métier quasiment car eux les
coiffures de fait par antoine dans les
années 1925 1930 sont encore d'actualité
ah oui donc j'ai pensé aussi à liz
taylor les coiffures c'est le grand
chignon de liz taylor ou encore jean
seberg la caution garde et coupé l'eau
chaude et tibère il ya maintenant 25 ans
et la coiffure de gilles cibert est
encore une deux une des images que nous
proposons actuellement la clientèle est
aujourd'hui donc est ce qu'il ya une
nouvelle tendance se dessine
on évolue vers quoi en ce moment dans la
femme l'évolution que nous tenons
surtout dans notre groupe nous ne ce que
nous nous nous faisons réellement et
dans tous les salons des anges en france
dont vous savez y en a pas mal 180 nous
sommes à l'écouté de la clientèle et
nous voulons faire une coiffure pour
chaque cliente
bon vous êtes vraiment à l'écouté de la
clientèle vraiment
[Musique]